[Applaudissements]
j'ai un groupe parce que toutes les
missions aux fêtes rené malleville alors
dit y'a l'occurrence le conseil de
classe et une prochaine ils seront
bienvenus c'est quoi la connaissait et
de kmh acheta un blouson en armes c'est
quoi
geoffrey c'est qui ce n'est pas vrai que
le jt avant le jt c'est toute
l'actualité du jour et corrigé par
patrick chan frais et on va parler
politique ainsi par une ou deux types
politique lorsqu une blague est forte
oui les humoristes sont tentés de cela
copier ça serait bien faut pas copier
mais sait pas combien
nadine morano fait encore plus fort elle
est la seule comique qui arrivent à se
piquer ses propres fans fort et ça on
s'est peut-être pas plus mal en même
temps dans l'absurde au mas est ce qu'on
continue à avoir une immigration massive
qui a la chine avec chez nous sur notre
territoire
je veux aussi qu'ils fassent le ménage
il faut que les musulmans fassent le
ménage dans leur communauté
j'ai vu une gamine de 8 ans une fois
porté un drôle de voir autant de toiles
et même des petites filles s'aimer mais
il ya 3000 ficher s pour radicalisation
les 3000 étrangers fichier s ur
radicalisation sur les 3000 étrangers
si chez ace sur notre territoire donc
faut arrêter avec la maif il faut
arrêter avec la naïveté pour les
renvoyer
il faut les expulser ils n'ont rien à
faire sur ce territoire
il faut les renvoyer divers
[Applaudissements]
une balle en deux jours toujours
gabriela talent qui n'est pas porte-clés
ni porte manteaux mais bien porte parole
du gouvernement
le message du gouvernement qui est un
peu flou en ce moment est beaucoup plus
claire pas beaucoup plus clair après ce
sera différent je prends parlera cet
après-midi et connais mieux les chiffres
que mon bien je peux pas vous confirmer
deux dates à ce stade voilà maintenant
encore une fois je peux pas vous dire
avant le premier ministre qui sera
annoncé je ne sais pas précisément je
peux pas vous faire les annonces d'hier
c'est pas mon rôle de le faire j'ai pas
le chiffre sur les récidives aujourd'hui
là aussi les détails vont être donnés
tout à l'heure lors de la conférence de
presse mais je n'ai pas ce niveau de
détail la laisse est d'autant plus
difficile d'être devant vous de répondre
à ces questions avant que les annonce
soit faite mais je ne peux pas vous
donner ce matin j'ai pas d'informations
spécifiques sur ces situations
moi je n'ai pas les éléments
[Applaudissements]
insolite un insolite à l'heure de la
crise sanitaire les vidéoconférences se
multiplient avec parfois quelques loupés
on les connaît depuis j'ai pas tromper
tout de suite le tour du monde spécial
zoom attention s'il restait bibs et 8b
[Musique]
un week end watch n'a pas lieu aux oméga
[Applaudissements]
par la culture culture exactement ma
part les cinémas parlons signer à
l'ozone signifierait luc besson a
préparé en secret taxi 6 et dans ce
nouveau dans ce nouveau volet pardon il
a tout misé sur l'une de nos meilleures
actrices internationales et le casque à
2 en exclusivité la bande annonce
[Musique]
merci de tout coeur
[Applaudissements]